sortent leur cinquième album ces
artistes irlandais se sont fait une
place de choix dans l'univers de la pop
depuis leurs débuts ils ont vendu des
millions d'albums pour présenter leurs
nouvelles chansons
ils ont organisé un concert privé auquel
assistaient origines ou de sa 1ere
manche à plat pendant des mois ils ont
parcouru le monde les cinq continents
donner plus de 100 concerts un million
de spectateurs sont venus applaudir
dolores et ses copains musiciens
après quelques mois de repos ils sont
retournés en studio
[Musique]
oh
les cranberries l'un des groupes phares
de la scène internationale qui décrocha
le pompon la super cagnotte en 1994 avec
le tube sanguine aujourd'hui une sortie
d'un nouvel album le cinquième un disque
produit à dublin dans leur pays
[Musique]
la liberté d'esprit c'est vital sinon
vous êtes bloqués ils tous avec vous
devez écrire pour vous ça vient du coeur
et là vous trouver l'inspiration
la pression c'est quelque chose que vous
créez vous-mêmes notre maison de disques
ne nous pose aucun problème pour
l'élaboration de nos chansons l'heure
des cadeaux
happy birthday dix années d'existence
pour un groupe qui accumule les
récompenses des dizaines de disques d'or
de platine au passage 32 millions
d'albums vendus
les cranberries restent fidèles à leurs
racines
beaucoup ont abandonné la pop guitare
basse batterie faisaient les maisons de
disques se sont tournés vers deux jeunes
garçons de jeune fille formaté
heureusement des groupes continuent de
se battre pour faire vivre la pop et
j'espère que ça fera naître des
vocations
[Musique]
amsterdam les cranberries ont offert à
leurs fans l'un de leurs nouveaux titres
la musique n'est pas révolutionnaire
pourtant le charme opère les irlandais
débonnaire ont tout simplement trouver
leur voie celle de dolores dans
l'univers de la pop
[Musique]